Lush and green but this part of
Catalonia is the epicenter of a severe
drought and the soil here is so thirsty
Manel pries won't even attempt to plant
corn this year
the plots of land lay Barren and parched
he's also worried about his barley crops
the grain should be plumper by now and
the stems elongated
normally the yield would be five to six
tons of barley kernels per hectare but
it's looking bad and this month of May
is key for his crop to mature
pero the stem is okay but the most
important thing is for the grain to
become ripe heavier if we don't have any
water this won't happen we would lose at
least 50 percent
this heat continues and there is no rain
before the end of the month then it
won't grow
it's been several weeks since the fields
were last irrigated and Manel doesn't
know when it could happen next
his rain-fed crops are completely lost
the irrigation canals are nearly empty
those lines show you where the water
level is usually at but since the
beginning of the year there has been
barely any rain so restrictions had to
be imposed to make sure there's enough
drinking water and it's the farmers that
are the hardest hit
one Village over in miral Camp is the
apple and pear trees that are at risk it
takes years of work and patience before
they produce the fruit
Josef Maria petrol says they require Sun
plenty of that and a well-drained soil
to bloom none of that here at the moment
he's now forced to use chemicals to
reduce the number of fruits growing on
each tree hoping on some rain to save
the others his brother Lorenz is
pessimistic
it's a chain reaction it starts from us
then the workers will lose their jobs
then The Butchers because their prices
will go up because there is no water for
the animals then some of the food shops
will have to close down it's a chain
reaction and we don't know where it
stops it's up to the government to come
up with a solution
Catalonia is considered one of the key
farming regions of Europe
with how the years shaping up an
agriculture disaster seems in the making
affecting people well beyond the borders
of Spain
foreign